Finally, the third way in which we're able to store information is through what
psychologists call an Associative Network. And this is a chain of associations
between related concepts. From pet, it could go to dog or cat, and from dog and
cat, look at how much it branches off. This is just a quick demonstration. I
could branch this a lot further. So, from pet, we could go to dog and cat and
from dog and cat, we could branch off so much more. They're both fuzzy, furry,
four-legged animals. I had a dog named Max. My whole family loved Max. He was a
golden retriever. And my friend Noel loved cats. And then that makes me think
of college, and then my friends, and how I majored in psychology. This is a
just a really short, quick example of how much this could branch off. I could
double or triple this if I had time, but don't worry I won't make you guys sit
through that.